so uh good morning everyone my name is
ryan mills i'm an assistant professor at
the university of michigan in the
department of computational medicine and
bioinformatics um also the department of
human genetics
today i'm going to talk about some work
we've been doing to explore
complex structural rearrangements uh in
using next-generation sequencing
so structural variants are chromosomal
rearrangements caused by the deletion
insertion and just generally shuffling
of genomic material one individual
relative to another
um large structural variants have been
long associated with micro deletion
micro duplication diseases and also a
hallmark of various cancers
uh smaller structural variants though
less well characterized or thought to
play roles in evolution population
differentiation and disease phenotypes
so when we say structural variation um
this is sort of a basic slide but just
to make sure that everyone sort of is on
the same page uh we're really referring
to the deletion of genetic material
relative to one individual
the duplication of genetic material
relative to another individual
insertion of genetic material
inversion where a piece of
of dna is actually inverted in
orientation and translocation now i say
what against another individual but
classically we use a single reference to
compare to although you don't have to do
this you can compare it between
individuals
so up until recently we've been limited
by the technology that we can assess
this and and there's a couple projects
about four years ago that
did large-scale microwave experiments
using uh cgh technology and and you know
at the time this was sort of the the
pinnacle of what we could find and uh
because the nature of cgh was limited to
uh copy number variation which is a
subset of structural variation that's uh
changes of copies of dna such as
deletions and duplications um and and i
want to point out that at the time sort
of the the
the smallest amount that we were able to
capture was down to 2.7 kilobases in
size
um
a recent paper by thousand genomes on
the pilot project a couple years ago
actually show that many many variants
are smaller than that range and so
there's this still unexplored space as
to what types of structural
rearrangements there are of individuals
relative to each other
uh so i think most people are maybe
familiar with next generation sequencing
by now i just throw the slide out there
sort of as a primer for those who may
not be as as
who may not remember exactly how it
works but in essence you're fragmenting
the dna sequences and you're fragmenting
dna into fragments and you're
essentially sequencing the ends of that
fragment and so you end up what we call
paired ins and these these fragments
follow a certain distance or these
paradigms are sequenced from a certain
distance of each other based off of the
type of library you do um and and you
can do cool things with this for
instance you can model
the distance between these and so if you
look at the actual
distance between a paired end when you
align it to a reference or are based off
your library you get this distribution
and regions that fall outside this
distribution then would be considered
abnormal
you also have the idea of sequence
coverage where the amount of dna you
sequence can be categorized it can be
modeled and and you again can find
outliers from from your expectations
and a third concept physical coverage
which isn't so much the amount of
sequences that cover a particular spot
but the the magnitude of the number of
fragments um that those sequence
represent and so this is really
important when when trying to find maybe
in you know breakpoints of particular
events even if you may not have the
resolution to figure out where those are
at
and so we can use this information and
we can actually uh
use it in different ways so for example
this is a small animation showing that
you take a fragment of a genome and you
sequence it you get sort of the expected
paired ends
but if there's a deletion there then you
still get the same size fragment but
when you map them back to a reference
genome they're further apart and so you
can use this to infer the location that
there's some sort of deleted sequence
there and if you have more fragments
that cluster together in the same way
then
your confidence that there's a true
structural rearrangement there or
structural deletion there uh is much
higher you can also use the amount of
sequence that's
the amount of sequence that's uh secret
the amount of the depth of the sequence
for a particular loci to determine
whether or not it's following your
expectations so if you have a mean
coverage of of 6x or 10x where you
expect 10 reads to across a particular
location of the genome and you find
deviations of that where you only see
half as much that could also be
indicative of a deletion although there
are other factors involved with this
such as pcr amplification biases and and
so forth
a third way of finding structural
variants is actually ident sequencing
across unique junctions that are made so
in this case we have a deletion where
you have the size of the deletion that
that come together to form a unique
junction and the sequence that you
observe then can't map back in its whole
to the to the reference genome so you
map it back in pieces and those pieces
can actually figure out where that break
occurred because they fall within the
sequence that you're observing these
methods have become a lot more prevalent
now that we have
larger sequences from the newer
sequencing technologies um
back when they were 36 base pairs it was
a little more difficult to do this but
now we have 250 and larger especially
with the even the third generation
technologies coming down
a fourth approach for finding structural
variants is this idea of denoble
assembly where you identify a region
where you think a structural break might
occur
and you
sort of outside of the reference try to
piece together the the the fragment of
dna from the sequences themselves and
then when you map that larger contig
back you can identify
uh individual
structures that may not have been found
find you may not have been able to find
them from the reeds themselves
so
these sort of four approaches have
really been developed you know more in
the last five six years and there's been
a number of projects that have used them
that they have been developed as part of
i'm showing here a couple articles from
the thousand genomes project but now
there's many others there's going out
there's uk 10k and and there's it's much
larger amounts of sequences that are
that are being analyzed and um
you know that as such there's a lot of
discovery algorithms that have been made
there's uh there's some in here that are
have been published almost seven years
ago um others are more recent um and
then they've certainly improved over
time
and one of the one of the big things
that we've sort of found is that you
know you can have a repair approach you
can have a read depth approach you can
have a split read approach
but you actually get a lot better
sensitivity
if you combine these approaches because
there are some some approaches there's
some region of the genomes that just are
not amenable to a paired in type
approach are are just don't sequence
well and so it's really hard to tell
whether or not it's a it's a pcr
artifact or if there's actually a real
structural variant there
um
as part of the pilot of the thousand
genomes we actually went in and we took
many different algorithms so on this
plot here we see different plus signs
and this is a figure out of the paper
but we have each of the uh individual
read pairs are in green read depth is in
yellow split reads are in red um and and
for the most part
you know most have decent false
discovery rates but their sensitivity
isn't all that great what we found is
that if we actually do um instead of
intersecting them if we look at unions
of these data in certain ways we can we
can increase our sensitivity without
hurting our uh specificity and so
in general this is kind of a neat way we
can just run a bunch of algorithms and
we can combine them together and then in
a clever way and we can come up with a
high quality data set and i this is
really
what most uh types of sequencing
projects do they run a read pair
algorithm they run a read depth um and
newer algorithms such as lumpy and delhi
and and gsav pro and some of these other
algorithms have now incorporated some of
this information into the algorithm
itself and so as a whole we're moving
into that direction
but the problem is is that i i it's sort
of the way that we expect what
structural variants to look like so i
this is sort of an exemplar region i
like to use it because i think it really
hammers home sort of some of the issues
um that that we're missing because of
the current way we do things and so let
me find my little arrow here so what we
have here is a 100k this is a hat map
sample one two eight seven eight some
chromosome three region there's a
hundred k deletion that's observed um
but on one chromosome on the other
chromosome we see a 40k deletion along
with a around a 10k small inversion
right at the breakpoint
and i i i put some generic algorithm one
algorithm too but but we've run a number
of algorithms on this genome and we've
looked to see how they handle this
situation and and no one really gets it
right and part of the reason is because
you have these overlapping events and
it's hard to pull out the final
structure based off of the signals that
are here
because these algorithms expect a
certain pattern of of what a structural
variant looks like so in this case one
algorithm can call the large deletion
but doesn't call the small deletion
another algorithm calls the large
deletion um doesn't call the small
deletion but it does call the inversion
correctly
but also caused the entire deletion as
an inversion
so
they're picking up some of the signals
but they're not correctly resolving what
the final structure is and so this is
what i would call a complex event it has
many different break points that are all
within each other
but they have some structure that's not
a simple deletion or a simple inversion
the thing is is that we actually have
information here to sort of tell us
what's going on here so in this row here
we have what we call clipped reads these
are basically split reads they're reads
that partially align to the genome where
a fragment of the reed doesn't and so
you see these at break points and here
we clearly can see potential break
points um of each of these events we
also have the insert size as we talked
about before this is a good way to model
sequences and we see peaks as some of
these variants uh break points but in
addition we also see peaks of reeds that
are mapped in opposite orientation so
when you have two reads that map the
same direction either forward and
forward or reverse and reverse
these are indicative of inverted
sequence since the proper orientation
for for
uh regular paired and sequencing is
forward reverse
and so we see these as well
on only a subset of these breakpoints so
so the signals are here and it's really
a matter of how do we use these signals
to define the proper structure of this
region
why is this important well what we're
finding is that this sort of complexity
is is is more prevalent than maybe we
had thought it to be so this is another
region same sample um and what we have
here is if you can look at that top this
is an igv uh screenshot from the
integrated genomics viewer at the broad
institute um and this this sort of top
panel here is the coverage
of um the sequence coverage and you can
clearly see a dip in coverage here and
increase coverage here so most read
depth approaches we'll call a
duplication or a deletion here but you
also see those these these colors here
and so green means that the reeds are
forward and forward and purple means
that they're reverse reverse again
indicative of a inversion but this isn't
a simple inversion what's actually
happening here is that a segment of the
genome this duplicated region is
duplicated
it's inverted
and then it's inserted at a deletion
break point
and these are all connected together and
so if you actually piece this genome
back together like as as we did at the
bottom of the screen here you see what
would originally started as a large
insert size after you make this
rearrangement you get this normal insert
size and so if you were to actually
piece together the reference in the way
that you thought that this rearrangement
went and you aligned all the reads they
would match up however the the the
problem with this is that
the misinterpretation of these regions
it's not an uncommon thing and looking
at the database of genomic variants
which is sort of a one of the largest
repository of structural variants that
ended that people have found during
their studies of individual humans
and we see that we have some signal for
an inversion here it's this purple line
here but it's going from here to here
which isn't correct we have some signal
for a duplication here we have large
deletions around here that perhaps are
picking up the break points but they're
they're they're picking up the break
points in a part of the sequence depth
difference but they're they're
misclassifying what the event is um and
this isn't just this reason this this
happens in in many places in the single
individual that we've looked at so
you know why does this happen well okay
sorry i should i should back up there so
this is on the simple case where you
have these simple complex events uh on
the large scale there's catastrophic
restructuring and so this is a project
published in 2012 that we played a small
role on basically it was a number of
individuals that they had sequenced with
originally with microarrays and i found
very little um cnbs very few inserted or
deleted material but in fact that it was
almost a chromothrypsis type event where
there was multiple chromosomes that have
been shattered and pieced back together
and the part of the problem with
analyzing this is there's really no
approach that can sort of resolve these
large scale rearrangements they're so
complex they're so confusing that you
can sometimes pick up pieces of it but
but you can't solve the puzzle
and you know this is significant and
that we're finding that this occurs in
cancers this occurs in the germline um
there's lots of of projects now there
that have these sequences that are have
these huge anemoploids they have these
huge
chromothrypsis type events um but it's
sort of difficult to to figure it out
and you end up pcr-ing up every single
break point and and then it doesn't work
and so then you you
you know you can spend a year just
trying to figure out what the break
points are for these events
so
this is sort of the you know the reason
that
other approaches can't really are many
approaches i won't say every approach
some approaches do better than others
but um the problem is that just looking
for clusters evaporate repairs alone
doesn't capture the entire event
and the sequence coverage is a very
useful model but it's spatially ignorant
you can know that a piece of dna is
duplicated but you don't know where the
duplication goes
um and split read alignments as i said
have gotten a lot better
with the longer reads but they still can
identify spurious break points
especially in duplicated sequences but
really the biggest challenge is that
there's so many different possibilities
of the way that you can delete duplicate
invert
genomic sequence that that having a
single profile type algorithm it is
really difficult to to be able to
capture um all the different possible
ways that the genome can restructure
itself
so
what we propose is sort of if we're
going to have these types of random
rearrangements and we should apply a
randomized approach and so we've been
working on a method and we call it
svelter um i'm not very good at names so
you have to forgive me about that um but
we attempt to address these limitations
um by first combining multi-faceted
sequencing models so we're combining
models of read pairs and read depths and
we're utilizing split reads at the break
points and we're trying to combine
everything together
to get as much information as possible
for individual junctions
and it's really based off of what i said
on that previous slide where outside of
expected error rates a correctly
resolved genome structure really should
have no aberrant repair mapping
distances orientation or sequence depth
variation so if i give you a reference
sequence and it's been structured in the
proper way and you align your sequences
to it there shouldn't be anything that
falls out as aberrant outside of just
the normal expectations from you know
sequencing error
and so just as a basic workflow and i'll
walk through it in more depth here in a
second but we we go through the genome
we scan through and we identify what are
putative breakpoints and this is very
similar to uh other approaches such as
uh lumpy and hydra uh that that do this
um and then we in an optimization step
we attempt to link uh sets of
breakpoints that we think are connected
to each other this is more to split the
genome up into pieces since to try to
randomly rearrange you know thousands of
breakpoints would take a very long time
um
and then once we have these sort of
clusters of breakpoints we we pick a
rearrangement we choose it at random
such as delete or invert and we we go
through
all possible
uses of that within a given set of
breakpoints and we score these based off
of no models of expectation of what we
think the reads should be based off of
um you know insert lengths and so forth
and then we choose a structure from a
distribution we derive from the scores
and we iterate this um repeatedly until
we come to a converged structure
our we hit our maximum and give up
and so to kind of walk you through this
what we do is so this is our again our
example and and again you can kind of
see clear regions that that could be
candidates for break points here and so
we go through and and we look for these
signals and i i don't spend a lot of
time on how we do this but we we look
for signals like this and we
um and we we count them as peter to
break points now they may not be putting
break points in fact if you look at this
this point right here there does seem to
be some some signal there but it's not
captured by read pair and there's not
really any kind of read them to support
this so this might be an indel our or
some other smaller event that's outside
the resolution that we can find and yet
we still incorporate it into our
algorithm since
if there's no signal there from the
other signals and it should fall out as
a spurious breakpoint
next we do what we call iterative random
rearrangement and so we take our series
of breakpoints we've identified we've
linked together and clustered in a
particular set of breakpoints and we
we divide them up into individual
segments so here just for a toy example
we have a b and c with some anchoring
region that won't move and we choose a
rearrangement at random we say all right
well what happens if we delete a segment
okay so all right we're using delete and
we apply so we apply this to each of
these segments and we scored that
segment based off of the number of
criteria i'll talk about here in a
second so you can imagine if we were to
delete a
now all of a sudden the distance between
these reads and these reads is smaller
but but the rest of the structure is um
basically unaffected if we delete b now
all of a sudden we we also have a
smaller uh
insert link between these two reads but
now we have unmapped mates and so this
is something that we need to take into
account that we're actually creating a
structure that's breaking normal reads
and if we create c we sort of kill
everything right everything's broken in
this case
so
and this is actually if you look at the
read depth here this is really the
complete opposite since there looks like
there's some sort of duplication there
and so we can determine a score for each
dis and the score is sort of indicative
of how well the structure after we make
this rearrangement matches our null
models and so we have our initial score
based off of the first structure we have
our first score which appears to be the
best and we have this last score here
where we deleted c was really bad
because it broke everything and that's
reflected in the score and then we can
build a sort of just a straight
probability distribution from these
scores and and pick which structure we
want to go with for the next iteration
based off of this this is kind of
similar to a give sampling markov chain
monte carlo where we're we're trying to
figure out where to go next and we don't
want ourselves to end up in a local
minimum and so we we do allow for
sub-optimal structures um with the hopes
that we'll you know that'll that'll
knock us out and get us to the the
global globally best structure
and so we have four different scoring
criteria we use and we've been spending
a lot of time tweaking these and getting
these to work we have the insert size
distribution for read pairs and so this
is basically um using uh uh we we we're
using a mono or a bimodal gaussian
distribution to to model the insert
lengths but it's basically the idea that
if you have here before you make a move
and you're here after you make a move
then this is probably a good move and we
can score this as sort of a a a naive
bayesian fashion from these gaussians
next we can use the orientation of the
repairs this is a little more difficult
because this is binary you're either in
the right orientation or you're not um
and so we we keep track of how many
reads have an abnormal direction over
the total number of reads and we can
sort of use this as a loading factor um
for our insert size distribution score
third we can use the expected coverage
of read mapping so if we delete
something that's um
at a particular location we can model
this by a negative binomial model again
this is something that's been done
before we're not breaking new ground
here but we're using sort of standard
ways of modeling sequence depth here and
um in modeling it in this fashion what
we can do is if we propose a deletion we
can actually change our expected mean
for that region given that we expect
there to be a deletion there and we can
model that and score that
and finally we keep track of the number
of repairs crossing a candidate break
point and this is sort of a important
aspect because here we have a bunch of
reads that map normally across this
breakpoint and we also have reads that
don't and so when you make this
rearrangement now all of a sudden you've
broken these reads and so we can keep
track of how many break points have
crossing reads so if i were to for
instance take uh a set of like if i were
to take some weird rearrangement and we
don't see any reads that fall over that
maybe i make a deletion and now there's
nothing that crosses that new breakpoint
that's probably not a real breakpoint
and so we can penalize that move to a
certain extent by keeping track of how
many reads cross it and this gets goes
back to that idea of physical coverage
um that i talked about earlier
and so we can combine all this together
um and it's kind of a um complex slide
we don't want to spend a lot of time on
it um we've come up with a number of
heuristic weights to sort of bring
everything together into the same scale
but we combine all these and we come up
with what we call our structure score
and so this is for a given structure we
for a given
rearrangement in each iteration we have
a score for that and we can then use
that score to compare the other
rearrangements
we can also use this as sort of a a
filtering strategy so if we get to the
end and we come up with our final best
structure and it's really not all that
great and this happens because some
regions of the genomes are just really
bad
we've come up with some methods for
looking and predicting for a given
region with a given number of reads what
we expect our maximum score could be
it's a prediction but
we try to estimate that and compare that
to our derived score and we can set a
threshold depending on whether or not we
want to keep the new structure or or
just filter that out
uh the final thing is part of the
approach is how we manage zygosity so
you know humans are diploid many many
organisms are
and so if you're just considering one
structure you miss overlapping events as
i was talking about before so what we do
is we actually start with two distinct
structures based off of uh you know the
diploid nature of our genomes and we
allow them to permutate independently
and so this this gets a little complex
because you have reads that could map on
each one independently
and so for instance maybe we delete a in
this top structure and we get this now
read that doesn't map so but we still
have the bottom structure which has
remained the same and so what we can
then do is assign that read down to this
bottom structure
here now that's going to change the read
depth at that location right for the
bottom structure but not the top topic
so you have to balance that out
and so this is sort of an example of how
we do this we go through here and we say
all right we start with two structures
that are the same
we can invert a small segment
and on one chromosome or on one
chromosome um haplotype and then we can
actually go through and maybe delete
from the other and each time we're
scoring this against both structures
simultaneously um and then we go back
and we update sort of our our original
structure and we do this again and so in
this fashion we can sort of take into
account these different um
rearrangements on both chromosomes
simultaneously and we can find these
complex overlapping events
and so
as i finish upward this is still an
ongoing project but um we've done some
initial work with the 17 individuals
that were released as part of the
platinum genome project there's a link
here it's a very nice set of data um
this is the seth pedigree 1463 of which
na12878 is a is a member of um and we
basically looked at our previously
assessed overlapping and complex
rearrangements across each individual
and so this is
again that first example i showed and
what we see is if we look at this region
and how we resolve this across the
entire pedigree of individuals so we
have one two eight seven eight here um
and these so a is the uh between this
break point and this break point b is
between this break point and this break
point c is between this break point and
this break point and so these these
segments are indicated down here by
different colors upside down letter
indicates an inversion and if you look
at this across the pedigree you see a
sort of um
expected uh mendelian inheritance
pattern which which suggests that we're
able to capture these correctly and
identify them in each individual um in a
similar fashion if we look at this this
other example that that i was showing
earlier um again we have this sort of
spurious breakpoint here
but we call it because of the signal um
but we also have these other break
points
and what we see here is again we we have
the same colors here um but but this
individual one two eight seven eighths
parents uh actually have uh the
are really the ones driving this uh the
segregation of these alleles and again
if you follow here you have um the
inheritance here from from the mother
and then of course you have a normal
individual here and you see every
individual having that allele and some
individuals having uh the the the the
multi-rearrangement and others having
the large deletion so this this gives us
confidence that we're able to actually
find at least this region correctly um
furthermore we've started to look at
what were previously identified as
simple deletions and we've gone back and
and looked at overlapping uh with with
the current thousand genome set this is
deletions that were identified one two
eight seven eight it's not the final set
but um it's close to the final set and
we've identified these regions that
overlap with what we consider to be
complex and i i think these are again
screenshots from one two eight seven
eight from igv and i i think it's fairly
clear that these aren't just simple
deletions that they're actually more
complex in nature and so our our our
our goal is to go back and try to
resolve this complexity and figure out
how many regions in the genomes have
been sort of identified as simple
duplications or simple deletions and are
in fact uh much more complex than that
and so our ongoing work is is you know
this isn't completed it's a alpha at
this point um we're working on our
algorithm optimization we're doing
targeted validation experiments and also
comparing with pacific bile systems
we're looking at adding features to make
them more applicable to cancer genomes
specifically a consideration of
heterogeneity within the zygosity model
and
we're particularly interested in how to
analyze large insert uh jumping
libraries where physical coverage is
actually more of a driving force than
than other signals
uh and with that i'd like to thank uh my
lab specifically jifang zhao who's
really done the vast majority of this
work
and then gargi tony nifon
and members of jeff kidd's lab jeff and
sarah who are helping us with the
validation um i i put a link up here to
the bit bucket of the current code
please keep in mind this is an alpha so
we're we're still working on the readme
we're still getting it streamlined for
for better use i was hoping to have it
better by this step but you know that's
research for you
and also the funding agencies so um
thank you and i guess i will take
questions now
um
and um
let's see here okay so i'm supposed to
read these here so
what is the minimum read length that
your method needs
does it work on exome data are all the
exon ends problematic for example
reducing read depth um currently this is
based off of whole genome i in theory it
could work on exome data but it's not
designed that way and would probably
need to be
retooled a little bit to do that um
the uh the minimum read length
it's not really a minimum read length
but typically you know we've been doing
most of our work with hundred base pairs
so i i would say at least you know the
standard you know aluminum two by
hundreds would would be fine longer
would be better um 75 base pairs would
probably work fine but i think anything
below that you're going to start to lose
some of your uh segmentation in the
genome uh the signal from that
do you allow multizygosity so yes there
is a feature to increase the initial
number of structures from two to three
we haven't really tested this at any
large scale but we have included that
feature um to you know for for you know
non-diploid species
but again it there's no reason it
shouldn't work it will increase the run
time though because now you're
permutating three structures and not
just two
why can't these regions be investigated
using traditional sanger sequencing well
they can and in fact they many cases
they should i think the question is how
would you know to investigate that
region for example if you have what's
called a simple deletion you know you
may not be interested in going in there
and investigating that region but if you
know it's complex now all of a sudden it
might be a candidate for your targeted
sequencing approach so i i think i mean
i'm a big fan of validation i'm a big
fan of experimental experimentally going
in there proving what what the computers
are saying
um
but uh but you kind of need to know
where to start to do that and a lot of
times uh if you don't know there's a
complex event there if you don't know
there's inserted sequence in your
deletion your senior may not work
because you're you know maybe it's too
large and you expect a deletion but
there's actually you know a large
insertion there so
um
that's part of the challenges with that
and we hope that this
algorithm will will help guide some of
that
molecular work
and i think a final question do you have
a sense of what proportion of previously
annotated
uh simple insertions or simple deletions
may in fact represent more complex
rearrangements that's a very good
question and that's the question we're
trying to ask um i would be comfortable
saying that it's probably less than five
percent
um of what's been found before but i i
can't put a firm value on that um
because we're still going in and
actually figuring out what might be
spurry's predictions of our algorithm
we're still trying to um figure out the
best thresholds and like i said we're
doing um validation right now um
but um but i i would probably say less
than five percent i have seen observed
some really interesting ones though
where you have you know duplications of
exons that are inverted and inserted
nearby what that what does that do to
splicing what does that do to
isoform regulation i have no idea but i
think these are very interesting things
that can be explored that um without
knowing where that duplication inserts
or even that it's an inverted
orientation um you know it could cause a
hairpin it could do all kinds of crazy
things so um you know hopefully we'll
have a sort of a new universe of um
uh of uh you know of things to explore
so um
actually what there's one more question
i'll answer real quick and then i think
that's enough how would your tool
perform in the case of cancer genomes
where you have multiple clones with some
of them having svs and some other not
okay so no this is a good question this
is a question of heterogeneity
right now it probably wouldn't perform
very well but the way we would we've
been thinking about this because really
this would be a main application of the
software and what we'd like to do is
adjust how we're handling our zygosity
to handle that you could have multiple
structures at the same thing so so
basically instead of having two
structures to start with for a diploid
genome you could have a third structure
that you weighed a little differently
and so maybe your expected coverage on
that structure is a little different
right depending on the level of
heterogeneity that you're exploring so
if you're expecting say ten percent then
maybe you would expect you know instead
of a 50 50 you'd expect a 44 or a 45 45
90 and you allow that third structure to
permutate for that um it's certainly a
challenge and we're working on
optimizing the algorithm first and then
adding these features to it but
in theory it should work it's just a
matter of tooling it the right way
so um i guess with that i'm out of time
and
thank you all for attending i appreciate
it and if you have any other questions
um
i i i believe they can still be asked i
think there's an option to send them to
me through this system so i'm happy to
answer anything and again if you like
check out the algorithm it's not
complete but it we hope to have
something in the next couple weeks
that's a little better to a little more
user-friendly so thank you very much